[Music]
hundreds of writers and editors now
looking to ruin conservatives
financially or otherwise by signing onto
a letter yes
and a letter titled no book deals for
traders
it demands that publishers ban memoirs
by former trump officials so i guess
degen
i guess that this is a an interesting
way to write or rewrite history
just simply ban the writing of it by
people you disagree with
this seems like a really easy solution
yeah if only people
only people listen to them i think that
there's a huge financial opportunity
and i guarantee you these book
publishers don't listen
to these uh these calls for cancelling
anybody who ever worked in the trump
administration
there's 74 million people plus out there
who would who would gladly pick up one
of these books
and especially again just make some
money especially given the fact here's a
little tidbit from the interwebs
frank and jerk jim comey's new book that
came out the first week of january
it opened at one percent of the first
week sales of his last book
it literally is the biggest drop-off in
the history of book publishing
so don't put your chips on frank and
jerk
mmm comey's not good with the tomies
huh how's that jesse for a rhyme you
know jesse
you could publish one pro-trump book
every day for the next 10 years and
still not match the contemporary output
of anti-trump screeds that are already
out there
so why do they need to ban anything when
they're so far ahead
because they're soft and if you think
about it the people on that list they're
not even editors
they're just small people they're in
academic circles that
they can't cut a deal with any of these
big shot trump people
even if they had the juice you're
telling me pence
pompeo meadows kushner stephen miller
those guys can't write their story
that's a part of the historical record
they were in the room for coronavirus
for the mideast peace deals for the kim
summits the american people deserve to
know that
this isn't the first controversial
administration that we've ever had
what about nixon and watergate what
about truman dropped the a bomb or
fdr put the japanese and internment
camps you're saying nobody that worked
for any of those guys gets to tell their
side of the story
that's absolutely insane
well you have to agree i mean you write
books this is scary stuff it
books should have daring subject matter
because people pay for the books it's
not
like twitter where it's free and
therefore you can ban it it's you know
this is like the last this is the last
bastion this is you you ban this stuff
it's over
well i know i see a little differently
greg because i to my mind first and
foremost
these are private companies and i think
you know they're publishing houses but
it's a private business and i think
conservatives would appreciate that a
private business has a right to set its
own rules and decide who they want to
publish
so i don't think there's any question i
mean right now you see some of the
radio stations setting rules for people
say you can't say
that the election was stolen let's stop
that or you see that uh corporate donors
are saying they don't want to back
people in congress politicians who took
part in trying to block the
certification of biden's win as
president so that i mean
these are decisions being made by
private companies and i think everybody
respects that
uh you know to my mind though if it was
a matter of censoring somebody i would
be totally against it
i don't think it's a matter of censoring
they say these people are traitors to
the republic
and they don't see that as good for
america
so that's interesting dana did you
notice that it's like um
they can control the distribution of of
speech
but if they decide because they're
pressured by a mob
it's okay because in their head they're
traitors right
so it's like it's you it's it's totally
okay to be pressured by a mob
uh to ruin somebody's career because you
know
and what drives me crazy is what juan
just said you can't now you just can't
say the election is stolen
what does that mean that you just can't
say something you just can't say
something that's where we're at i have a
right to say stupid things
as i have proven many times on this show
thomas spence is the publisher of
regnery and
they picked up the josh hawley book they
published a lot of conservatives books
and he said that um first of all he
thinks that this letter of the 500
is like really kind of like junior
staffers so
they're again the younger staffers are
making it harder for the
adults but the adults need to talk about
pounding sand go do that
um the other thing is these books get to
be more famous
um greg you're an english major i know
you've read all you know
all the books that you can think of in
history that were like have staying
power
they were controversial or they were the
ones that people try to stop
those are the ones that actually i'm not
saying that josh hawley's book is going
to be like some like
high literary event um but i will also
say this
if any of those people that you
mentioned pompeo uh tillerson any of
those people
if they said if pompeo said to the
publisher
i'm going to tell you my full story and
i'm going to include
seven examples of where donald trump was
terrible
he would get a big fat book contract
and that book would be controversial the
last thing i would say is
all of these publishers all of them try
to get their authors
on fox news because fox news readers
viewers
are also big readers so keep that in
mind too
yep yeah no but your point about
its young people this is the chilling
future
we have young people who do not believe
in the first amendment
they don't they they believe that if
they don't like your opinion it should
be
silenced that didn't exist before and
it's shameful that established authors
aren't standing up
to this kind of and defending others
absolutely by the way
can i just add one quick thing the
people
who were indoctrinated on school
campuses and college campuses they are
now within the halls
and at these big tech companies that are
now censoring conservative voices
that's who they are yeah mm-hmm
so you know you're safe if you're not
writing a daring book
that's why i wrote the plus an
incredibly dangerous i wrote everything
will be
the five coming up next